so what are your thoughts on Andrew he's
very funny I feel like I have a lot of
fun chatting with him I also think he's
a trafficker he's laid out very specific
instructions on how to lure women in how
to cheat on their taxes it's like
standard pimping 101 like he'll talk
about like bringing a new woman he'll
get that woman to convince the new woman
to do like X work without him actually
saying anything he's even talked about
like oh yeah like when I'm doing taxes
for these women I'm supposed to pay them
50 50. but he'll steal like 20 on the
taxes if the woman says like well hold
on how much am I paying he'll like print
out some fake tax forms and give it to
them they're like okay I trust you he's
explaining there's all of this yeah now
it could all just be fake and he's like
lying and exaggerating it all but if it
is true it's obviously struggling